how do you define what's too much how do
you define when chasing women becomes
too much
you know
i was thinking about this over the
weekend because i recently rewatched the
linkin park jay-z mashup i don't know if
you guys ever you know got a copy of it
or ever saw it but there was a live
collab that they did together and one of
the songs that they collabed on was 99
problems but it
ain't one
we've got to try to water down the
language today for youtube you get a
hugging language yeah we huggle
you know what i'm saying one percent
joke yeah yeah um but i mean like as far
as it goes i mean if you're finding that
you've got a lot of problems in your
life
and women are becoming a big part of
that because you're chasing them way too
much or they're creating drama in your
lives or throwing hissy fits and you're
tolerating it that's a pretty good sign
that you're not on a purpose and that
you're not chasing accidents in the yard
chasing women because it tends to
dominate you know your every thought
movement idea
planning everything you know everything
that you do it's like why didn't you
call me it's like
you know i get these subscribe
notifications from reddit now and it's
like every freaking day i've got two to
three that i share on twitter i don't
know if you guys have been seeing them
or not but it's like
you know well this chick was alpha widow
and she clearly banged that guy when she
went away on vacation it's like you know
all these things keep popping down and
guys keep complicating them a lot you
know complicating their lives because
they're not on a proper purpose they're
not on a grind and it's like these women
invite chaos into their lives and they
let it happen it's not like you know
they want it to happen you know they
think that everything is sugar and spice
and all things nice but that's what ends
up happening if you're not on a grind
first you know you got to put yourself
first that's what the whole concept of
mental point of origin i mean would you
guys agree would you disagree like what
are you guys all thinking uh you know
this is a pretty timely topic because
there was a gal was dating for a while
that you know we're essentially
some of the folks i was closest to you
know even my business partner was like
hey man we need all this brain power for
all the investing and all the other
stuff we're doing and this chick is
taking up way too much brain space yeah
and uh
and you know one of the things you you
always say rich and i think it's 100
true it's like is she a compliment to
your life and if she's not then
what what are we doing here and so
uh
you know i had to
get out of that relationship because it
was like this is
way harder than it needs to be like your
sister you're making this way more
difficult
and the roi guys
hi paul the the roi is just i i look you
you know my story i've only been back in
the game in the last year and i've done
i've done way too much chasing it costs
too much money it's too much hassle and
it it's
you know i said it to myself today more
men need to be seen returning from the
hunt okay i've been studying the male
archetypes from ancient rome
and i recently moved on to organized
crime and the mob um you know when john
gotti came home from jail
women were leaving notes on his
windscreen of his car okay because they
go after the you know the guys who were
chasing success and who were ignoring
the women and what we've all been
conditioned to do is oh your life will
be complete if you get a perfect girl
and i just said the last few months i've
been doing way too much of it and
instead this week i just put two hours
into connecting somebody from our group
who's introducing a product to the us to
two major influences and influencers on
twitter and possibly a national radio
show host and that is far more
satisfying than racking up numbers and
not counts
because it's in our dna and that's what
we should be doing first yeah we got it
reversed as i said we got it all
backwards
is there is there a point where like you
know like the whole chasing tail and the
whole notch count you know like
accumulation is like okay this is
getting silly
you start to get burned out after a
while like you just get tired of it it's
i
i equate it to like any addiction so
rich when you're describing uh coming in
on the top of the show how guys it
consumes every thought i remember when i
used to drink a little too much like
moving to a new neighborhood or moving
to a new town i'd always look like all
right how far the bars like is it within
a walking distance is there like a party
neighborhood or something like that and
then that solely transitions to
a new addiction because you're like oh i
can get girls now and then it does go in
your head like all right well are there
girls nearby or guys you'll know like if
you start going on the red pill journey
and you hang out with beta friends like
oh bro let's go to ikea there's girls
there oh them all girls girls no no
we're
we're good but you got to get to the
point where it doesn't consume every
thought anymore and then
make that to where your purpose consumes
your every thought and i admit i think
i've been there before and i'm sure most
the guys on this panel probably have too
where you're just like you just get
burned out you're like
i'm not getting anything out of this
paul you wanted to say something i saw a
little bit of a
a chuckle there yeah yeah it's it's all
bs like you know like when you can't
it's all a bunch of bs and i teach guys
how to
get the girls it's part of what i do
and i always warn them i always tell
them it's all bs because look at these
pickup artists
what happens
they end up
banging a bunch of girls cool they end
up running their little
you know they end up running their
business and their you know their
weekends and all that and then they end
up in relationships most of them
and then they end up getting you know
having one itis a lot of times and
having all kinds of problems and there's
all the stories of these guys in the
pickup community who you know find that
toxic chick and they can't figure out it
like destroys their business or really
screws them up so what happens because
they've made women their focus
and while there's nothing wrong with
solving a reproductive problem
it's like working out if i made my diet
in my workout program
my obsession unless i was a
competitor or it was part of my vocation
also
whereas teaching other people and
competing and stuff i would probably
you know fail in other areas of my life
and i'd be pretty miserable
wouldn't be able to afford you know my
my gym membership after a while right
because i wouldn't be doing anything you
know i'd probably over train i'd
probably do a lot of things to harm
myself well it's the same thing with
women you know it's not that you
shouldn't
figure out how to game and how to do
well with women and how to be attractive
and not be unattractive and how to have
good
in fact it's really important that i
would say to learn how to have good
relationships with women in your life so
that they're compliments to your life
but
if you're making the focus you're
chasing them you're it's like the main
thing you're accomplishing
it it's a recipe for disaster i did that
i know i was gonna ask you like how do
you know when you're when you're doing
that and that you gotta kind of reel
back on yourself like how do you know
when you're in that position where
you're like screwing up
well it's just that you're not
accomplishing your other goals and what
you got going on with women is consuming
your thoughts
and instead of
you know
okay i'm focusing on what i'm doing and
then i have things going on with women
over here it's like that's consuming you
you're missing out on accomplishing your
work goals your business goals
your your vocation your hobbies the
things that
you need to be doing to either make the
debt in the universe or to find what
that thing is
you've you've lost focus and passion for
that things and now you're just working
on
the next thing with the girls you know
and i
got to a point where i left a marriage i
was in you know in between deployments
living out of my car because it was
stubborn i didn't want to get a
different place and so i would stay at
different chicks houses for like you
know a little over a couple months i was
like a freaking gigolo
i've never been able to do that
these and these were girls like it
wasn't just a bunch of like old ladies
or something you know what i mean like
it was
some of these girls a lot of them were
younger than i was you know what i mean
that had you know i'd be staying in
their bed or whatever for a couple days
you know they lived on their own or
whatever they were you know you're a
chad when you're like a homeless guy
driving around in a car living in
different women's homes right i was
man
you don't need if you don't need a big
house like
paul benjamin dude wait i thought you i
thought you needed a lambo to pick up
chicken right yeah
bro
give me yours
i was a dirt bag in between deployments
just smashing through girls girls who if
you saw their instagram photos would be
something that dudes would be like oh my
gosh let me let me let me uh
it's really slide into her dms and be a
shoulder to cry on right right
yeah we've seen these let me see if i
can nice my way into her love
it's ridiculous anyway my last point on
it is just that i i got to a point i
went god i'm i'm a i'm a freaking
douchebag right now i accomplished some
my accomplishments were all past
accomplishments in the military like
right now i'm between stuff and i'm
doing nothing and i'm crashing hard and
fast you know what i mean i'm just
partying and being a douchebag i i gotta
stop doing this
what's the point of it all
there was no point you know i was just
overcoming
past you know
pain and
stuff that i was just dealing with yeah
instead of just working on myself and
overcoming the real issues it was a
distraction for me facing my real
problems overcoming those and finding
what i was going to do with my life you
know what i mean and that's what it
turned into and that's bad place to be
you can get addicted to drugs well you
can get addicted to this too oh yeah
there's there's definitely guys out
there that get addicted to women for
sure
you